hey youtubers it's Charlie so the
internet just blew up they just showed
some Captain America Civil War footage
at d23 along with some early stuff from
Doctor Strange so this is gonna be a
breakdown of that now they're probably
not gonna post that footage online but
if they do I will post it just careful
for spoilers from the end of ant-man
because they showed some scenes that
followed up on the end of a man and the
post-credits scene so here we go
Falcon wearing a new suit says eyes on
target folks and he launches a red wing
it's his new drone they're going up
against crossbones that's actually
really cool Easter eggs from the comics
because Falcon has a real-life Falcon in
the comics that's called Red Wings I
mean it's like a red Falcon that he
shares a telepathic link with because he
was affected by Red Skull tinkering with
the Cosmic Cube it's Captain America
Falcon in Black Widow going after
crossbones in a bomber kind of reminds
you the end of the first Captain America
movie cap and crossbones fight while
Falcon and Black Widow take out his
henchmen crossbones says this is for
dropping a building on my face his face
actually isn't that bad they're gonna
they're gonna CG it but he has scars
across half of it he's not as ugly as he
is in the comics and then he also says
you know he remembered you your pal your
buddy
you're Bucky then Thunderbolt Ross says
the world owes you an unpaid debt but
while a great many see you as a hero
there are those who prefer the word
vigilante people are afraid cap says we
try to save as many as we can but
sometimes that doesn't mean everyone
then we get a follow up to that scene at
the end of ant-man the post-credits
scene
Bucky recognizes Steve then Captain
America says I know we're not perfect
but the safest hands are still ours and
that Iron Man replies back if we have no
limitations we're no better than the bad
guys then we see black panther and is
full on glory in his suit it looks like
this there's a fight between Black Widow
and Hawkeye then the rest of the
Avengers are charging into each other we
see vision and a new suit so this is the
climax of the film when people have
chosen teamcap or teamironman then it
cuts to a scene of ant-man being brought
in to meet Captain America this is
probably the best part of the footage so
he walks in and he's all he's all
flabbergasted he says Captain America is
an otter I'm shaking your hand too long
this is really great I know you know a
lot of super pee
and then it gets super awkward so he
says so thanks for thinking of me in the
news light gets all flabbergasted and
said thanks for thinking of me and
corrects himself and he touches his PEC
just like Peggy Carter touched his PEC
in the first Ironman film so just a lot
of Awesome awkward ant-man humor so
really the biggest takeaway is our Ant
Man joining team cap crossbones is the
biggest villain early in the film like
he's the biggest of all the small bats
the biggest antagonists the people that
you could call the big bats are general
Thunderbolt Ross he's always gonna be an
iron man and Baron Zemo but of
all them the only ones that you could
really call a true villain would be
Baron Zemo just because of his Hydra
ties that's the thing about Captain
America Civil War there's a lot of
antagonists but only a few true villains
because this is all about the line in
the sand that Captain America and Iron
Man draw now if you read comic book
civil wars then you know crossbones has
a really big role to play in the
conflict with Captain America but please
use spoiler tags because there are a lot
of people that probably haven't read it
now in the comics he does have some
special powers that his gear gives him
we might see those in the film or it
might just be like the extra you know
the added tech he might just be like an
evil version of Falcon like you know
Falcon is a superhero but it's mostly
done through the use of technology
he doesn't have really crazy abilities
like vision speaking of which everyone
generally seemed really surprised to see
so many Avengers in the film but we kind
of knew that earlier this year I think I
did a video about the the general cast
they're probably gonna be a few
surprises that Marvel will hold close to
their vest but for the most part this is
like Avengers 2.5 more than a Captain
America film but Captain America is
still the core of the film you know even
though they have to introduce Black
Panther they have to introduce
spider-man I think the only real
disappointment of this is that there was
no spider-man in the trailer but you
can't fault them for wanting to save
that for like some big official trailer
reveal they didn't really say when the
next big trailer is gonna come but it's
totally possible that they can hold it
all the way to Star Wars Episode 7
they'll definitely show a trailer of
some sort before it but they might
release official footage before then
we'll see November is a really big time
for people to drop footage like that but
Star Wars isn't out till Christmas what
I'm really wondering is if we're gonna
see any Easter eggs for Dark Avengers in
this movie like you have the sanctioned
superhero
the ones that Thunderbolt Ross backs and
then you have Captain America's real
Avengers remember Norman Osborn
spider-man universe even though
spider-man is crossing over I'm not
expecting to see iron patriot Norman
Osborn in this movie so if you have read
comic book Civil War just think of Ross
as being the Norman Osborn character in
that story sometimes they'll do that
will they give like multiple storylines
to single characters they'll just
they'll make them an amalgam of a couple
different comic book characters really
it was that Captain America footage that
brought the hall down this is a big day
for Star Wars for Disney's other
live-action stuff they showed a big
slide of all their movies till the end
of time is ridiculous there were crazy
baby but it's all of Disney stuff
including Star Wars and Marvel so what
I'm gonna do next is I'm gonna post a
Doctor Strange video they did show some
promo art and Benedict Cumberbatch did
that thing like he does at comic-con
where he sends footage and saying you
know thank you for coming sorry I can't
be there this is gonna be an awesome
movie that that kind of stuff they
showed off some concept art for Doctor
Strange too if you saw my Marvel
giveaway that I announced yesterday what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna leave this
open because I'm also doing a Doctor
Strange video because they did release
footage they actually released Doctor
Strange footage too I'm adding the
giveaway I'm making it even bigger what
I said was is if they release footage I
would give away three gift certificates
versus just one if they didn't release
footage but they actually had some stuff
for Doctor Strange too so I'm giving
away for Amazon gift certificates for
$20 each for different people so all you
have to do to enter that is be
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video I'll announce the winners later
today whenever I post that Doctor
Strange video I do know for sure that
Marvel said it's not gonna release any
of that Doctor Strange promo art online
now the Captain America Civil War
footage might make it online eventually
but they were making people wrap their
cellphones up in plastic bags as they
walked into the convention hall so we'll
see just stay tuned for Captain America
Civil War footage it might end up
leaking we'll see if it post officially
then I can do another new video on it
maybe Hydra will leak it again like they
leak The Avengers trailer last year hail
Hydra let me know that how do you guys
feel about that description of the
Captain America footage it's pretty
close to what that reddit person said I
did a video yesterday there was someone
on reddit saying that they had seen the
footage it was pretty close half of the
Avengers are gonna be in the movie so
they hit some of those bases right but
they didn't
a lot of the comedy between Ant Man and
Captain America which I felt like was
the heart of the footage there was some
really funny stuff there was some
villains and then there was like some
hero on hero action like Avenger on
Avenger if you guys didn't see it you
can click here to watch that and you can
click here to watch my Doctor Strange
video I'll update the annotation as soon
as I post that in a little bit thank you
so much watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys a little bit
there's still a bunch more stuff coming
today